you're watching quite coming up on this
week's show how robot DJs and pedal
powered fridges kippie helping create
tomorrow scientists I have a go at
controlling a scalextric using mind
power and who doesn't love a puzzle
we've got a messy one in this week's
games review welcome to swipe this week
run the Big Bang fair and firming and
the UK's biggest science technology
engineering and math event it glows a
call Suffolk and there are plenty of
budding young scientists and inventors
in fact blueprint will to meet a few of
them as I find out what innovations we
can look for in the future Sean get him
i created a drug to diagnose and treat
the early onset of outsiders I've
invented a cycling jacket with
indicators so I've invented a new
revolutionary high-altitude weather
balloon shuttle
I've invented the light that helps
dyslexic people to read young people
here have a lot of big ideas and the
organizers hope that by making science
and technology fun they can inspire kids
to become future programmers and
engineers when you're looking at a
textbook sometimes it's difficult to see
how what you're doing in school relates
to what you might do in the future and
this really brings it alive whether you
might want to go into coding you might
want to be involved in building things
you might want to be involved in in the
medical world it's all here and there
are people that have gone through the
same sort of decisions in the past that
you can talk to one of the more unusual
things here is this the DJ robot it's
mechanical arms can play music and even
dance to the beat
but its real purpose is to demonstrate
how robots are used in food production
modern factories rely on automation and
these machines do a lot of the work this
robot could do anything from icing on an
Easter egg so writing your name on any
stroke it could deal with the rap in a
wrapped product to actually push it onto
the next operation it could actually
lift up quite some heavy pallets ready
for dispatch a prototype from bae
systems uses sound in a different way
instead of using headphones it conducts
noise through bone using this tiny
speaker it's been designed to improve
the way soldiers communicate now this is
something anyone can have a go at as I'm
cycling the movements are making are
powering the fridge behind me it's been
designed to show young people how
refrigeration works from keeping data
centers cool to chilling your food this
technology powers a massive industry
engineering as a whole really suffers
from a lack of skills mainly because the
STEM subjects aren't deems attractive or
exciting but I think this show here is
strike what we're trying to do to turn
that around or at least help to turn
that around much of the technology you
see here may never get past the
prototype stage but young people testing
it out could be inspired to create their
own inventions will sergeant skynews
stay with us because still to come we'll
be finding out how to control one of
those using purely the power of
the first it's a roundup of some of this
week's cover tech news pigeons have been
recruited to tackle air pollution in
London equipped with sensors on their
backs and a Twitter account they've been
sending data back to pigeon patrol HQ
the project's creator said he used
pigeons because they're low fast-flying
means they're able to gather accurate
readings and beat the traffic sony's
announced when it will release its
virtual reality headset playstation
users will be able to get one in october
meanwhile facebook's oculus rift will be
available in the u.s. later this month
and the HTC vive is due in april you
might not have heard of the chinese
board game go but over in South Korea
it's huge and in Seoul this week a
computer beta human asset google
deepmind took on go champion lee sedol
and triumphed for one is the first time
a computer program has defeated a
top-level player a 15 year old from
somerset sled a drone racing team to
victory taking first prize at an event
in two by luke banisters tornado ex
blaze bayley UK 174 thousand pounds
after beating russian and dutch
competition in the final race around a
Tron esque glowing track and fresh on
crowdfunding site indiegogo this week is
what's claiming to be the world's first
portable stone Bake Oven it's wood or
gas fueled and with temperatures up to
500 degrees C the makers say it can cook
a pizza in under 90 seconds stick around
for our games review will be down on the
farm in stardew valley there's so much
to see and try out here too much in fact
but just this one episode of white
but when I heard about a mind-control
scalextric I wasn't going to leave
Birmingham without having a go I've got
my head elica ok so the headset is
connected to the computer which is
connected to the scale at uniform and
and you are relaxed and you're almost in
this form of fairly amedisys team which
is releasing our boys by your neurons in
your brain they release electric
impulses the only reason the car is
neither is because you're nice and
relaxed yeah whereas I'm hot which is
why the blue car is really struggling
that guy said yes because when we're
talking to you soon as you start talking
to me which is why the yo car stops as
well you're not you're not relax the
focus anymore so there has not moving so
we developed the connection between the
headset for you at war at University and
our fourth year group and over the last
two years has been a project and we're
couraging kids to get into standby show
engineering applications so we connected
the mind-control headset with a retro
Tori to make it
just a bit of fun or are there other
uses of technology okay so your actual
the scale at trick is a bit of fun but
they're wide applications is that you if
you have more electrodes you can connect
it to a wheelchair and get a better map
of the brain so you can control
direction as well as just be so it had
potential users the people
anyone with a muscle wasting disease or
paralysis you can also connect headsets
to diagnose things like epilepsy if you
have a better man
unusual brain function or brain activity
so there's lots of lots of applications
that's a really awkward coming area
there are plenty of games here for kids
to get stuck into and now it's time for
our game slot this week's review will
make you think we've got puzzles and
we've got racing what better combination
is Martin tella pain is a new iOS game
from acid nerve a two-man studio who did
Titan Souls which came out last year on
ps4 much greater claim to kind of retro
styled game this one is a puzzler it's
got this kind of 80s children's TV vibe
to it we're Pickers large filter but
like really cute ascetic hides is really
really mean devious puzzle game where
basically you're teleporting around and
it's one of those amazing puzzle game
that starts off really really simple and
then gradually layers in mechanics until
by the end of it you're doing things
which are crazy and kind of mind melting
it's a really really good iOS game it's
organized fit for that studio style and
this one the best games i played an IRS
this year so it can strongly recommended
star g valley has been an absolutely
huge success on steam it's kind of taken
everyone by storm it's one of these
games has come from nowhere basically it
is a meld of old games like Harvest Moon
and look with animal crossing and with a
slightly modern edge and a bit of a
Minecraft the edge to it as well you
basically are in charge of the farm and
you go around and you plant stuff and
you attend your crops and you have a
little village to the ground basically
it sounds very very simple there's an
awful lot to it it's a really refreshing
change from kind of more aggressive
video games it's super relaxing but it's
also one of those games can kind of
consume your whole life before we know
it and you end up waking up at four in
the morning just panicking wondering if
your parsnips of grown
TrackMania turbo it's trackmania is a
long-running series on pc by french
teacher called nadie and they have been
hugely successful on pc massive fan base
brilliant driving games kind of really
short sharp arcade racing games they've
never really had much success on console
it never really made a concerted efforts
go on console they have now with
TrackMania turbo and it's brilliant kind
of opening up the the thrills the track
mini-games to a wider audience it's a
more accessible trackmania and it's just
a really beautiful game it's kind of
takes trackmania and gives it the the
veneer of a 90s arcade racing game
basically and so it's super coachable
and really really really finished Lee
difficult and loads and loads of fun
well that's it from here in Birmingham
take a look at Sky News on mobile iPad
and catch up all the latest tech stories
throughout the week see you again next
time bye-bye